on fait des voitures très performante et
on ne peut plus rouler alors là je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on faisait en
1990 bouleversements dans les villes
françaises la vitesse maximale passe de
60 à 50 km/heure et certaines
municipalités comme mulhouse vont encore
plus loin avec l'instauration de zones à
30 km heure le but réduire le nombre
d'accidents
si un petit gosse qui sort d'une voiture
et puis qui courent sur la route 50 km
heure on arrive sur lui on n'a pas le
temps de l'éviter
quelques mairies comme strasbourg
gif-sur-yvette en essonne vont suivre le
pas en installant des zones 30 aux
abords des écoles en 1992 lorient d'une
pionnière transforme tout son centre
ville en zone 30 avec des voies plus
étroite et des ralentisseurs là aussi
dans le but de faire baisser le nombre
d'accidents
une initiative plus ou moins bien perçu
contador c'est suffisant a précédé une
expérience 38 robin ya moins d'accidents
moins de six mois de cela c'est très
bien mais les chiffres d'affaires des
commerçants sont un peu en baisse malgré
les réticences les zones 30 se développe
car en plus de voir baisser le nombre
d'accidents les maires mettent en avant
à partir des années 2000 les autres
bénéfices d'une diminution de la vitesse
lutte contre la pollution contre les
nuisances sonores circulation apaisée
avec les cyclistes on peut redistribuer
l'espace public de façon à ce que
quelque part tout le monde y trouve son
compte et pas simplement l'automobiliste
donc c'est un signal fort pour
l'automobiliste de lui dire vous n'êtes
plus le mettre dans la rue mais dans une
ville où la voiture justement a
longtemps était la reine difficile de
faire entendre raison aux automobilistes
en 2011 par exemple les strasbourgeois
étaient invités à voter pour ou contre
le passage à 30 km/heure dans leur ville
et c'est non les strasbourgeois ne
veulent pas être limitée à 30 km/heure
sur 70% de la voirie de la ville
mais plus les années passent plus les
associations de cyclistes de piétons
sont nombreuses à réclamer une
circulation plus douce les zones 30
deviennent ainsi un argument de campagne
dès 2014 à paris est née réalité pour
d'autres agglomérations comme celle de
grenoble
en 2016 une première en france à cette
échelle et puis ce matin divisait les
automobilistes dans les bouches pour
savez d'écraser les gens c'est mieux ou
contre ça complique encore plus qu'avant
et on mettra une heure et demie pour
faire 18 km aujourd'hui en france
seulement une quarantaine de communes a
mises en place dans toute sa ville une
limitation de vitesse à 30 km heure
[Musique]